we are back with the comedy tag team of
our dreams casey wilson and daniel
schneider
all right
let's hit those headlines because this
is the news after all and we love to
source interesting facts things that are
happening casey kick us off please hey i
will so honored to do this so first up
scorned taylor swift lover jake
gyllenhaal is speaking out
l reports jake has not listened to
taylor's red album or the song about him
but he says it has nothing to do with
him it's between taylor and her fans and
she uses her personal life in her music
i feel like jake gets it
right but that being said jake did turn
off the comments on his instagram when
the album came out and about that he
said and i quote here i think it's
important when supporters get unruly
that we feel a responsibility to have
them be civil and not allow for cyber
bullying in one's name
in
one's name i mean i think we all know
the name that he means though
right yeah i think that part's great i
will say and i i like uh jake gyllenhaal
i just don't believe that he hasn't
listened to the album okay i'm sorry i'm
sorry but it puffed the magic dragon it
was about me i would listen to it you
know like i would and i would study
every single lyric do you think come on
you said what my thought bubble was
which was you listened you listened you
had no shame you have wouldn't you guys
listen if there was an album that was
sort of about you wouldn't you i do feel
though i would listen and he still has
the red scarf right but i still feel
like he
is afraid of taylor's army as am i he's
i mean i feel like we could send in
taylor's army instead of the national
guard i mean they are
terrified have you had because that what
attracted me to this story was his
saying
listen
all's fair in love and war however
cyber bullying
fans getting out of control
that angle i kind of did appreciate me
too yeah have you had interaction with
taylor swift fans ah
yeah yeah yeah you have no we might have
made an errant comment on the podcast
and it was with so much love and respect
for taylor and i want them all to know
that yes and i will say that it was done
in the heat of the moment and i meant no
wrong and please don't come for me i
have a child and this is a public
apology actually yeah
all right danielle your story okay so
everyone is freaking out over the tinder
swindler the new documentary on netflix
about the guy who allegedly
scammed his dates out of hundreds of
thousands of dollars he says it's and i
quote not true but now the new york post
reports he the swindler himself simon
leve just signed with an agent now you
might think he'd be running under a rock
to hide but nope he's headed to
hollywood baby and he's got big plans he
wants a dating show where women have to
compete to date him
what do we think
uh well okay there are how long it took
me to get an agent
crazy but i am i am tech avail for any
project simon
you know i just think there are so many
bad people on dating apps you know and
at least this guy has a job you know
what i mean like now yeah he's out and
he's a hustler he's working he's on
cameo so he's working at least
i love how now i'm like i can't believe
you'd accept that kind of behavior
meanwhile we're drooling over pen back
because he's yeah okay now ross we have
a surprise coming out
good luck good luck all right next up
there's a new documentary in the works
about a true tv tv icon do you guys all
remember the psychic hotline legend miss
cleo right yes
i always wanted to call her now every
time she said i was like oh
i can't afford it well if you if you had
a tv in the 90s you should you couldn't
miss her here's a little reminder
you have questions
i have the answers well the huff post
reports the doc is going to dig into the
woman behind the psychic her real name
was yuri delharris and reportedly you
know she wasn't a psychic from jamaica
she was an actress from l.a why yes no
for reals the psychic readers network
pulled over over 1 billion dollars yeah
in revenue until 2002 when uh oh the
federal trade commission just sued them
for deceptive advertising and billing
oopsies and the doc the documentary is
going to dig into all of it and reveal
more about miss clio and whether she was
an accomplice or perhaps a victim in the
fraud billion-dollar industry from miss
cleo i'm sorry when this documentary
comes out i'm going to binge it now
i can't wait for this wow i have to say
i'm glad that she's not around now
because i would have spent all my money
i'm into astrologers
psychics the whole thing i went to a
psychic once and i do love this stuff
but when i came out my car had been
towed and i do wish she had told me
it's so true yeah
she's thinking far in the future
well i have to say i'm really excited by
all these fascinating documentaries i
feel like documentaries have always been
around they're nominated for academy
awards we love them we learn from them
but i feel like they're just really ever
present right now and i can't get enough
of them i'm on the documentary feeder
[Music]